what do you make of these latest
developments and where this is going
next ultimately it's up to a judge to
decide but can you quite get your head
around the fact that there
allegedly are top secret documents that
have been taken from the white house to
a private residence by a former
president
well given that it's donald trump we're
talking about i'm not surprised in the
slightest and i wouldn't be surprised if
there were more highly classified
documents at bedminster or some some
other uh residents of his i just think
it's important that everybody whether
they're pro-trump or anti-trump or
whatever their position is to try and
take a deep breath here let this process
play out you know the the the filing
that was done last night in the united
states that included that picture that
you've shown there and a lot of
information about the documents and
about
trump's uh obstruction is the word they
use the refusal to turn them over to the
national archives is revealing bit by
bit the the seriousness of the case and
uh we we don't know all the details yet
it could be very very serious but my
strong urging to everybody is stay calm
let's let it play out we've got due
process in the united states the facts
will come out here but let's not jump to
conclusions that the justice department
is an arm of the democratic party
on the one hand or the trump ought to go
to jail tomorrow on the other uh we
don't know enough at this point to have
an informed judgment as i say more is
coming out and it's been negative for
trump without any doubt in my mind but
but we don't have the full story we need
to be aware of that yeah we don't have
the full story and as you said it's
important for there to be the time for
due process to
to run its course but in terms of the
seriousness of what we're seeing again
with donald trump you know people tend
to gloss over it treat it as a bit of a
joke but just how serious this is this
and how serious could it be for donald
trump as an individual because he could
face criminal charges
right well the central question is
what's in these 320 or so classified
documents and it's a large number of
documents
not to be in a secure location
but we we really need to see what's in
the documents uh to get a better sense
of it and the
director of national intelligence in the
united states is now doing in effect a
damage assessment of it and i think we
need to await the outcome of that
analysis for trump himself i think it
could be dangerous
i would just say this is a matter of
politics you know when an ordinary
citizen is in that kind of circumstance
and justice
felt there was a legitimate ground to
prosecute i think they just go ahead and
do it but with a former president you
have to
acknowledge the reality and you may not
like it but it is a reality that uh he's
a very high profile figure
and if the justice department decides to
proceed here it better be more than
certain
uh that it can prove its case if it if
it if it goes after trump or his
associates
it better be very sure it's going to win
in court
uh john bolton former u.s national
security adviser always good to talk
thank you for your time this afternoon
here on sky news